الحوسبة الكمية دخلت عصر الفائدة العملية
يعني إننا نقدر نبدأ نستخدم الحواسيب الكمية لحل
مشاكل من الواقع الفعلي، منها مشاكل صعبة جداً
على الحواسيب الكلاسيكية
نمط شائع في الوقت الحالي
إن مشكلة معينة تنحل
لأول مرة على حاسوب كمي
وبعدين الناس تلاقي طريقة تحلها على حاسوب كلاسيكي
هذه الدورة من الحوسبة الكلاسيكية
والكمية اللي تدفع كل منهما لحدودها
غالباً راح تستمر
لسنوات قادمة، وفيه فئات من المشاكل حيث الحوسبة الكمية
تقدر تحقق ميزة قابلة للإثبات
على الحوسبة الكلاسيكية
بالنظر للتقدم في مجالات مثل
تقليل الأخطاء وعدد الـ qubit المتاحة
وفيه كمان مجالات تطبيق كاملة
حيث الحوسبة الكمية
ممكن تكون مفيدة في المدى القريب نسبياً
من بين هذه المجالات: تعلم الآلة الكمي أو QML
تعلم الآلة الكمي يشير إلى
تطبيق الحوسبة الكمية على أي نوع من أنواع
عمليات تعلم الآلة، وطبعاً فيه
أنواع كثيرة من تعلم الآلة
نوعان بالأخص مثيران للاهتمام:
التعلم المُشرَف، حيث
تدرّب خوارزمية باستخدام مجموعة بيانات مُصنَّفة
والتعلم غير المُشرَف، حيث
تعمل الخوارزمية من عينات غير مصنّفة
وتحاول تتعلم عن التوزيع
أو الدالة اللي تولّده
خوارزمية التعلم غير المُشرَف ممكن
مثلاً تتعلم كيف تولّد عينات جديدة
من نفس التوزيع، أو كيف
تجمّع العينات في مجموعات ذات خصائص متشابهة
كل من التعلم المُشرَف وغير المُشرَف غالباً يتضمن
تضمين البيانات في فضاءات ذات أبعاد أعلى
والتعامل مع البيانات في فضاءات ذات أبعاد أعلى
يجب أن يذكّرنا بالحوسبة الكمية
خليني أوضّح، تخيّل إنك تحاول تحل مشكلة تحديد إذا
نقطة بيانات في المستوى تصنّف
كدائرة أو كصليب، بالاعتماد على بيانات التدريب المصنّفة هنا
أحياناً يمكن فصل البيانات بوضوح بخط
أو مستوى في الأبعاد المنخفضة
كما هو موضح هنا، وتصنيف نقاط البيانات حسب
ما فوق الخط
وما تحت الخط ما فيه
مشكلة، لكن انظر لهذا التوزيع
واضح ما في خط مرئي يفصل نقاط البيانات
لكن لهذه البيانات نقدر نتخيل
تحويلاً من بُعدين لثلاثة أبعاد
بحيث بعد تطبيق التحويل تصبح بياناتنا
بهذا الشكل، وهناك مستوى واضح يفصل الفئتين
اللي نقدر نستخدمه
للتصنيف، لو هذا الشرح يبدو مبسطاً نوعاً ما
أنت محق، ما نقدر نرفع نقاط البيانات اللي نريدها
لأعلى بدون مبرر
لازم يكون في تحويل
من التوزيع ثنائي الأبعاد يفصل
نقاط بياناتنا فعلياً حتى نقدر
نستخدم التحويل لتصنيف نقاط بيانات جديدة
هذا سيُناقَش أكثر في الدرس اللي يعطي ملخصاً
لتعلم الآلة، لكن يكفي إن نقول
إن المشكلة يمكن النظر إليها
كمحاولة عدة تحويلات مختلفة لهذا الفضاء الأعلى بُعداً
لنرى أي التحويلات تعطي أفضل
فصل لنقاط بيانات من فئات مختلفة
هذا التعامل مع البيانات في أبعاد أعلى
هو مجال واحد حيث الحوسبة الكمية
قد يكون لها تأثير كبير، ولفهم السبب
لنرجع للفروقات بين الكلاسيكي
والحوسبة الكمية، تماماً
كما تستخدم الحواسيب الكلاسيكية bits من المعلومات
الحواسيب الكمية تستخدم qubit
لكن لعدد معين من الـ bits، مثلاً أربعة
الحاسوب الكلاسيكي يقدر يكون في أي من
اثنين أس أربعة أو ستة عشر حالة ممكنة
الحاسوب الكمي يقدر هو الآخر يصل لستة عشر حالة ممكنة
لكنه يقدر يوجد في تراكب فوق كل
الستة عشر حالة في نفس الوقت
ويمكن تنفيذ العمليات على هذا التراكب الكامل
لأربعة qubit هذا قد لا يبدو
كبيراً، لكن تخيّل ما يمكن عمله مع
حاسوب كمي في اثنين أس عشرين أو
اثنين أس مية وسبعة وعشرين
حالة في نفس الوقت، وفيه فروقات كثيرة أخرى
بين الحوسبة الكلاسيكية والكمية، كلها
ستلعب دوراً في هذا الموضوع
الحالات الكمية لها سعات احتمالية مركبة
العمليات على الأنظمة الكمية تُنفَّذ باستخدام
مؤثرات أحادية، والحواسيب الكمية تخضع لأنواع مختلفة
من الضوضاء عن الحواسيب الكلاسيكية
هذه الفروقات ستظهر
في عملك بتعلم الآلة الكمي في مجالات
مثل ترميز البيانات وتحديد الميزات وتخفيف الأخطاء
في بعض الحالات، هذه الفروقات بين الكلاسيكي
والحواسيب الكمية تسمح لنا بتصميم
خوارزميات جديدة كلياً، هذا كان نظرة عامة مختصرة جداً
على تقاطع مجالين بالغَي التعقيد
لكن آمل إن شيئين باتا واضحين
تعلم الآلة كثيراً ما يحل المشاكل
بالتعامل مع البيانات في أبعاد عالية جداً
وثانياً، الحواسيب الكمية مناسبة جداً
للتعامل مع البيانات في أبعاد عالية
وتفعل ذلك بطريقة مختلفة عن الأنظمة الكلاسيكية
هذا يجب أن يعطيك إحساساً
بسبب كون تعلم الآلة مجالاً واعداً
لتطبيق الحوسبة الكمية المفيدة